Ahsoka awakens in a mysterious ethereal
place and then she hears two little
words that only one man would ever say
the most likely explanation is that
Ahsoka has fallen into the world Between
Worlds a Mystical Force realm outside of
time and space that she briefly visited
in Star Wars Rebels perhaps the magic on
cito's opened a gateway to the dimension
just like how Ezra opened one to save
Ahsoka from Darth Vader in Rebels or
maybe her arrival there is true divine
intervention some kind of cosmic
correction to keep her on her path
regardless Anakin's involvement in the
scene marks an important moment in Star
Wars history christensen's version of
the character has never interacted with
Ahsoka before as she doesn't appear in
any of the Star Wars prequels however
their relationship has become one of the
defining features of Anakin's character
their reunion no doubt makes for a
powerful moment for longtime fans
especially given that's the last time
they met in Canon they were fighting to
the death I won't leave you
not this time